so it's been a tough couple of weeks for
right-wing conspiracy theorists and
overly microwaved baked potato alex
jones looks pretty done put it in there
for another three minutes the pioneer of
pizza gate who spent decades spreading
outlandish stories like lady gaga being
a demon and tap water turning kids gay
is embroiled in a very public custody
battle i hey guys
he just wants his baby back baby back
[Applause]
jones ex-wife claims he is quote not a
stable person what ha this guy not
stable you're in the cult bro you're the
threat to america you are who we're at
war wind you traitorous little rat
Kasane take those kids they'll be fine
Jones's legal team is trying to justify
his unhinge rant by claiming he is just
a performance artist playing a character
and his lawyer actually said like Jack
Nicholson it's the Joker in Batman Fame
can say well that's not the Infowars
kingpins only species legal argument in
a deposition Alex Jones admitted he
smokes a marijuana but quote right here
to monitor its strength which is how law
enforcement doesn't
which is wife Snoop Dogg was deputized
he's just testing it all out for the
rest of you what a public service
comedians what's another both legal
defense you might hear from Alex Jones
Timothy diamonds uh Your Honor I only
put those cameras in the bathroom to
find out who is flushing the baby wipes
they are really messing with our pipe
all right Eric Your Honor you saw how
fuzzy those bunnies are how can I be
blamed for petting them so hard their
spine snapped yeah Your Honor I was only
Manning that truckstop glory hole to
count how many perverts are in El Paso
yeah